et maintenant les sports allez les
garçons
et bien oui c'est Pierre Blanchet qui
vous parle en direct de Roland-Garros où
se déroule actuellement la finale
comptant pour le simple messieurs qui
oppose bien sûr le Suédois bjornborg à
l'américaine Jimmy Connor et à l'heure
où je vous parle c'est Borg qui passe à
Connor ce qui passe à Borg qui passe
le Connors qui passe à Borg qui passe à
Connor
qui passe à bord qui passe à Connor et
comme convenu je vous retrouve dans un
petit quart d'heure
match je sens surprise hier soir sale
nado content pour la Coupe de France des
tireurs de couverture qui opposait la
jeune brestoise Janine Barrois au
savoyard François Bégude
résultat vous allez le voir très attendu
très attendu ce qui explique sans doute
la faible assistance lors de cette
compétition
les deux concurrents s'observent
et ce sont évidemment les petites
d'usage
ils vont se mettre au lit c'est un début
de match vraiment très classique
[Musique]
de lit
et voilà c'est parti
c'est parti sur un vous allez le voir
tout de suite un premier tiret latéral
de bigut qui n'inquiète pas vraiment
Janine Barrois qui va répliquer par une
habile prise de drap à laquelle bigute à
son tour réplique par un superbe ramené
découvrant
qui a vu scarfait moins le public est
venu pour s'amuser bien sûr à ce
moment-là on croit encore que le match
peut s'envoler
le public qui croit lui-même
[Applaudissements]
et puis non et puis non bouillez c'est
un Bédard sans aucun brio debigüe on
aura celui au passage la présence dans
le public du synthétique c'est
l'excédent québécois le gruyer
[Musique]
c'est étonnant non